[Music]
and costly mistake news oh oh I hate
when that happens
submitted by con leche with milk legit
good job porque queso their cote po PO's
it nobody knows what that means anymore
maybe the people speak Spanish out like
building more hey he asked me yesterday
how do you say cookie I'm like I don't
practice I'm like 40% of think he knows
more than they do yeah la pelota I
understand it pest with the rock are
there the Boca what do they mean
open your mouth but Joe understands just
as much - yeah Joe's very intelligent as
well now Don and I have been around
we're both bird that was your kids a
woman who was an active juror on a
murder trial through the whole thing
into chaos with the Facebook post oh you
know I'll do that you're not allowed to
do that girls on a juror juror a case
and she put it on Facebook you're not
allowed if you talk about the case I'm
supposed to sign like oh yeah
against alcohol have you guys been on a
jury yes I have and I get so nervous
well cuz you're not supposed to speak to
reporters or ain't nobody you can and
they're family you can't you talk to
other juries sometimes they don't even
let you leave no you're not supposed to
talk to other jury members you're
supposed manilow like while she's there
she's updating Facebook of what's going
out this guy can you believe it yeah
that's crazy though yeah don't they
specifically tell you don't they 100% to
tell nobody being people were gonna find
out on Facebook she's like I only got 15
followers anyway these are just my
favorite facebook a savage cells out
there look so this woman she says that
her 15 year old sister made the
which so this was a comment under an
article talking about this case oh so
she commented sitting on the jury
lmao left my ass off no the tip yeah
sitting on the jury that's not it does I
thought the little sister of the juror
wrote that that's what she's claiming
you're still not even supposed to admit
that either though because if it's a
high profile case you're gonna get
killed or swayed or a lawyer or who
knows you could get killed if inside
come on be a case yeah they're like oh
what's this person doing are we sitting
there like well I did do jury duty one
time I went Senate twice I didn't get
chosen say yeah after that yeah I've
been on a case so nerve wracking do you
talk about it I think so after it's done
it was a drug deal oh that's fun it was
it was I kind of interesting once you
get into it but then talking to the
jurors after is really nerve-racking
because I was young I was probably like
21 and everyone's grown-ass man and we
like a lawyer in the group and I'm like
oh I'm feeling intimidated like she
couldn't say something you know and then
and then and then the second time I went
I was almost gonna get on a case and I
tried to tell the judge like hey man I
can't really be here like I have a lot
of work to do like I run in my all my
own businesses and and I just don't make
money if I can't he's like what what do
you do oh right podcast yeah yeah I said
online male entertainer and he said well
how long's your you know channel been
around or whatever and I was at all like
three years or something cycle sounds
like a pretty successful so you can take
a couple days off and then just [ __ ]
these shows are oh god damn bro no
you're supposed to pretend that you're
racist on like a the interview you yeah
it was on a malpractice thing like a
medical malpractice and I just kept
throwing like well I'm a personal
trainer I have a lot of really good
doctor friends I got no tons of physical
therapists I'll probably be biased here
and then they all chinks are good
doctors the politic you like I'm nervous
as [ __ ] this was something like two
years ago to think you weren't even on
trial I'm so nervous
I've never been in trouble in my life
can I get nervous
seven I stole something but I want an
accident not for you dude I think I've
moved so much since then that I just
don't get any letters anymore you can
get in trouble you can have you just
updates his license right if they don't
if he doesn't reach it it is his fault
that means he didn't you feel like
Tillett County everybody you have to
update I think you have like 30 yeah but
I don't get letters are you supposed to
update it maybe because I haven't voted
in a while to bench warrant I'm not a
good imagination warrant I think you
could have a bench warrant out for you I
remember I went to jury duty i sat there
and then the they picked the 12 and I
was just in the audience then they're
like you could leave no that's nice
alright cool that's what happened then
you're done for that whole year so I
served yeah okay then I did serve jury
duty oh nice
that is your service thank you for your
service and what yes what I'm a senior
I'm gonna start doing Jerry Jerry duty
though [ __ ] watch law law and order just
show up every day yeah you need somebody
like please leave get my thirty dollars
a day no no it's not a slow ok so this
case here it's a New Jersey murder trial
and the suspect is Liam Liam Mukesh ask
me mcdhh a see Mike I don't know I just
make it up so he is charged with fatally
strangling his childhood friend oh [ __ ]
was it over Mario Kart watch I'm Sarah
and he dumped her body over a bridge in
order to steal her inheritance novella
[ __ ] right because if it was over a
videogame I understand it gets heated
and you chose Luigi and I want to be
Luigi you know not mean like yeah you're
definitely a [ __ ] Mario so Sarah was
19 when she died yeah so she had told
him Liam that her mom she had some money
stashed away she found it after her
death and so they were he was heading
over to her house to count the money
together Wow and that's one
she trusted him yeah he said that ad
took half an hour to kill her and I keep
pretty much like hung her with his arm
and you got to be real psycho I feel
like to do that no method of killing
I've never killed no one but like if I
was hypothetically gonna kill someone no
I'm not gonna do it hypothetically here
on the Internet in terms of game form
I'm covering like I feel like shooting
somebody in the heads quick right like
big but it's loud yeah no no but I mean
like morally you can't even feel that
keep your pulse low and you like
poisoning them you know oh you don't
have to see them I wouldn't know how to
poison them I'm not an assassin but that
would be the move probably sent I
thought they'd always grab like a
[ __ ] eye drop a nickel yeah it's my
ring yeah yeah yeah I mean the more I
hate them the more personal I want it to
be so if I hate them Bart is dark them
yeah I hit someone's guts on my shooting
so easy you want to slobberknocker
well of course because there's emotions
involved but if it's all like business
like which is this case he's just doing
it oh yeah then you'd probably what the
you just yeah you just want to do it so
he thought that he was gonna get so okay
he told his former roommates to help him
get rid of her body oh my god two
[ __ ] psychos yes right that's scary
when they meet up chose his roommate
over there was Preston [ __ ] Preston I
knew it so that's when Preston like
threw her body in a bridge I'm sorry in
a bush near her house and then Liam like
backed out of her car cuz he liked
galleries a security camera across well
I know exact I do this a thousand times
I know exactly how she pulls out of her
driveway so I did it the same way
whatever so like he actually like has a
confession when he was telling a friend
like this entire story the friend was
working with the police and got so many
backstab this sounds like a movie yeah
was a hidden camera in his car in this
friend's car that was working with the
police and so you can't trust anybody in
this town no so he did get a video of
him talking about it which I'll show you
in a second but they ended up fine so he
said that he ended up stealing about ten
thousand dollars but he told it so your
mom thought that he was gonna keep that
but he was gonna get a hundred thousand
dollars that's all just still not a no
wait so he killed her
thinking that it was a hundred thousand
dollars he only got ten thousand dollars
and this was so this was cash that was
left in a shoebox by her mom over years
too so all this one hundred thousand
dollars does not fit in a [ __ ]
shoebox she stupid [ __ ] idiot
so this [ __ ] idiot came over and
killed her and then counted the money
and said oh not only that if this as
money as old like it's not even in
circulation anymore in its I can't even
use this maybe use of that you [ __ ]
wait wait so it crumbled and fell apart
in his hands Oh your cream this is Liam
who killed Sarah I don't trust anybody
else like that
Oh Sarah Wow oh no why that's the worst
picture ever is there like blood on her
neck I don't know Oh tie-dye tie-dye
yeah and then this is the video of him
of him talking about it this is insane
showed to the court so wait so he's
admitting to his friend we're gonna get
her but before I play this out I just
need you guys to know because of that
stupid I'm sure they're trying his
lawyers are trying to call for a
mistrial probably yeah probably get it
exactly no probably get it oh my god
wait oh because now they're they're
saying oh she tampered with the evidence
now we don't know whose yeah yeah but
she's it she has been removed what a
dumbass big right she get to go to jail
at least I hope this town's full of
idiots
[Music]
I took now
recording the funny thing is this guy's
like the problem is the dog just watched
her as she was getting killed like he's
like trust the dog the dog didn't even
hope nobody's disappointed in the dog
he's like can you believe her dog she
would just watch me kill her
yeah that's twisted so Preston I bet you
that's not the first time you killed
somebody maybe no not with that attitude
[ __ ] he's like I was I was freaking out
he was freaking out that the cop almost
I don't know who the [ __ ] talks that I
was really freaky god I was losing my
[ __ ] what super humid strange
31 [ __ ] idiot dance this stupid [ __ ]
couldn't keep her mouth yeah I think
they do another child oh I might be
wrong that's right look it just happens
all over again cuz that's like him
straight up saying like I did it this is
what I wrote well but the notes you
might be able to throw they might have
to throw everything out now yeah they
might have to oh yes that's all stupid
yeah so his lawyers are saying like the
defense he was saying well all that that
you caught on tape that was just an
elaborate story of a friend telling
another friend
there's lied just so he can impress that
friend that's what the the lawyers are
saying like are they going there on
Preston she's still dead so it's not a
lie right who did it suppressant agree
like he he testified against him he
pleaded guilty he's facing between 10 to
20 years for helping him get rid of the
body
so it's like dude you [ __ ] did it
Preston came out yeah because Liam's
lawyers were trying to say
imagine having to defend that guy that's
disgusting that's kind of a weird job
talking to some lawyers and lawyers
friends like that's a fine line I don't
think I could do they're super
desensitized right because they look at
it case by case and they see it by
waning so they're in a different world
well he might even go in there and say
look Liam I don't care if you did or
didn't let's talk about how we're going
yeah yeah you don't have to tell me I
don't want you to tell me if you did it
or not and if I know well Karen you'll
just move on yeah lawyer just moves on
and tries to win because think about how
how how great that lawyers career can be
right like he actually gets a guy off
murder or this guy's pretty much
guaranteed [ __ ] be in jail but he
gets him off rights devil's advocate any
keeps it yeah and if he keeps doing it
yeah he's gonna get a really big career
he could be like the guy that always
gets off do you Simpsons lawyer yeah he
could like yeah and then you know
actually he'll get a pick up hero and
Kardashian right oh I'm not sure yeah
that's yeah yeah
[Music]